Get rich or die alone.
The stakes have never
been so high, you guys.
Hey, everyone.
Laci Green here.
It's been a while since we
talked about online dating here
on DNews, but a new study
that's getting some attention
caught my eye.
Scientists are claiming
that-- prepare yourself
for this one-- online daters
with an income of over $150,000
per year get a crap load more
messages from potential dates.
For men, they were 82%
more likely to get messages
if they made over $150K
than if they made $20K,
and for women, they were
65% percent more likely,
which suggests that
money can in fact,
buy you love because all
everyone wants in life
is a sugar mama or a daddy.
If you don't make 150K
per year, have no worries.
Most people don't including the
people that are claiming to.
In analysis on OkCupid found
the average person lies
about their income by as
much as 20%, so in reality,
most of these folks are probably
making closer to $120,000
per year.
The analysis found that
the exaggeration becomes
more pronounced as you
get older and that men
are more likely
to lie than women.
The other reason
you shouldn't worry
is that you don't have to
be in the top 5% of earners
in the country to
succeed in online dating.
We found that starting
around $80,000 a year,
you'll start to get a lot
more messages than all
the lower income brackets.
The folks who are
most screwed are
those who make $40,000
or lower because that's
when the messages really
start to drop off.
So what are some of
the other groups that
have a winning edge in
the online dating world?
Well, being white certainly
helps if you're a man.
OkCupid found that
white men lead
the way in the number of
messages they receive compared
to every other race of men.
For women, those
of Asian descent
lead the way in
messages received.
An analysis of two million
users on PlentyofFish
found that it's
very advantageous
to describe yourself as
having an athletic build.
This improves
responses by about 40%.
Also being Christian or Catholic
improve responses by about 30%.
Overall though, the
greatest advantage
is to have those
dollars, which gives me
all kinds of mixed feelings.
I mean, what happened to the
best thing in life are free,
and you can't buy my love?
I guess those mantras will have
to stick the Hallmark cards.
So why is this so
trying to begin with?
Evolutionary psychologists
say that class and income
are valuable traits in a
mate because it tells us
about how much
resources someone has.
The argument goes that the more
resources, the better they're
able to care for
their offspring.
They can put a roof over their
kid's head, food on the table,
send them to college,
and essentially ensure
that their children
too will have
lots of resources, aka, money.
So maybe there's
something there or maybe
we've all been convinced
by our money-driven culture
that we'd be happier if we have
a giant house and fancy cars,
which is [? oblique ?]
disputed by scientists,
but that's a story
for a different day.
Thanks for joining
me for DNews, guys.
How much does income matter
to you when you date?
Let me know your
thoughts down below,
and I'll catch you next time.